-Welcome back, everybody.
I'm here with the one-and-only
David Schwimmer.
Thank you very much
for doing our show.
I really appreciate it, David.
-No problem. Yeah.
-"Intelligence" -- super-funny
show.
Already got picked up
for Season 2.
-Yeah.
-So congrats on that.
It's on Peacock, which I was
playing around with
this weekend, because,
obviously, it's our network,
and I was -- I just wanted to
see what it was all about.
Not bad.
-Yeah.
-Actually good stuff.
I got into it and, like,
I was already watching your show
in two minutes.
It was great.
-Oh, good. Thanks.
Thank you.
-I like your
physical comedy in this.
There's some nods to, like, a --
like Peter Sellers-ish
sometimes.
There's one where you run
and slide down the --
and just fall off the desk.
-Yeah.
I mean, I love physical comedy.
You know, I grew up -- I don't
know who your heroes were
when you were growing up,
but, like, as a kid,
I was addicted to Monty Python.
You know, I would watch
and study those guys
as much as I could
and I'd mimic.
I'd just try to do every single
silly walk there was.
And, yeah, so, I mean, I just --
I was hooked early on.
-Did you entertain
at parties for your parents?
-Not at parties, but --
Well, probably when my parents
had folks over, company,
I would probably be
inappropriately jumping in
and hurling myself
against furniture.
No, yeah, I mean that's how --
I just loved
making my family laugh --
my parents and my sister.
So I'd just be bouncing off
the walls
and hurling myself
over couches and --
Anyway, when you're young,
you know, you don't get hurt.
It's only much older
that you realize,
"Oh, I'd better develop a
technique, because --"
-Yeah, when you're a kid,
there's no technique.
You go for it.
I pretended I was Chevy Chase
like every single day.
I remember once, I fell down the
stairs with paper plates
and I was like, "What..."
I could never even --"
And I'd be like,
"Is there a stunt thing?
Is there a pillow
just to make sure it's safe?
And should I wear a helmet?"
I could never get away
with it now.
Do you want to set up
who you play on the show?
-Sure. So, "Intelligence" --
it's a workplace comedy,
but it's set in London --
well, outside London --
in Britain's version of the NSA,
which is called GCHQ.
And they're really dealing with
national security,
cyberterrorism, and cybercrime.
And I play this kind of pompous,
arrogant alpha-male American
who's shipped over from the NSA.
I'm an NSA agent who's shipped
over to work with the Brits
on a new program
where we combine
our intelligence
and our resources.
And I basically assume
that I'm in control
and I'm over here to run things,
when, in fact, we learn
that I've been demoted
and the NSA is trying to, like,
get me out of the spotlight
because I've been --
My activities
have been perhaps
less than honorable at the NSA.
We find out a lot about,
you know,
my character
as the series progresses.
But, basically,
it's a workplace ensemble comedy
set in the high-stakes world
of national intelligence.
-Did anyone from the NSA
reach out to you at all or...
-I'm assuming they're reading
all of my e-mail and --
-They were watching you.
Yeah, even before this
interview aired,
they're like, "Great interview."
-I got a random e-mail
with notes on Season 3
and -- No.
Yeah, no,
we haven't spoken to the NSA.
Although Nick,
the creator of the show
and my co-star,
he did meet with GCHQ,
some reps from GCHQ,
who wanted to make sure
we weren't kind of, as they say,
"taking the piss."
-Yeah.
-And they were --
I think they were reassured
that we were going to
make them look good,
even though we're a bunch of
kind of misfits
and incompetents.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's David Schwimmer in
"Intelligence."
Take a look at this.
-One of the things I've
started to realize is that
it's much easier doing this
when you have color photos.
-Gosh, that's a very diverse
bunch, isn't it?
-Thank you.
-I'm worried
it's a bit too diverse.
-Okay, so, what I've done here
is assimilate all the data
from the program,
along with Tuva's trace matches
and combine that
with an algorithm
that basically mimics
my own gut instincts.
Anyway, taking all of that
into account,
these are our top-six suspects.
-You know two of these
are the same person?
-Yeah. It was a test.
You passed.
-My thanks to David Schwimmer.
His show, "Intelligence,"
is streaming now on Peacock.
David, I really appreciate
you coming on.
Really, thank so much, bud.
-Thank you, man.
Thanks for having me.
Stay safe.
-I hope to see you in person.
Yeah, you too.